comment devenir éco-responsable après
vélizy ouille verneuil et montrent la
jolie l'exposition n'en jetez plus et
habiter écologique
conçue et réalisée par la cité de
l'architecturé du patrimoine se
déroulent à la maison de l'environnement
de magny les hameaux
à travers des photographies des chiffres
saisissants et des éléments ludiques
l'exposition explique les bonnes
pratiques écologiques du quotidien et
les différents enjeux d'un habitat
notamment à destination des enfants
l'économie de l'eau quand on se brosse
les dents c'est cacher ce qui semble
assez évident après il y en a d'autres
qui sont peut-être un plus inconnu comme
par exemple la veille des appareils
électroniques où ils peuvent simplement
débrancher les appareils pour économiser
l'électricité c'est la consommation de
l'eau qu'on me prendre une douche et
qu'enfin la représentation visuelle avec
les bouteilles
c'était chose qui les marquent les
enfants ont également construit des
cloisons de maison imaginaire à l'aide
d'un cadre en bois de bouteilles en
plastique et du papier journal pour
faire face aux défis écologiques ils
sont désormais prêts à changer leurs
habitudes
la sphère de bas parce que j'en utilise
beaucoup de dauphin il douchez banshees
bordeaux du coup bas
farrar et douches qui va tous les soirs
470 kg c'est le poids moyen des déchets
de chaque français par an une
consommation qui contraste avec celle
des pays du sud il est des télés ou une
télé un lit
oui on a ils ont plein les machines à
laver plusieurs canapé puis à sceller
tout ça il y en a ils ont juste des
bolzes et des cuillères pour 10
personnes lors que l'ona qui sont que
que quatre qu'ils ont rappelé anne plein
de choses
l'exposition n'en jetez plus et habiter
écologique se déroule jusqu'au 24 avril